today's question comes from James in
North Carolina and he says at what point
do you need to involve an estate planner
when planning your will or can you just
go online and complete a will
well we recommend mama bear legal forms
for your will it's about a hundred
dollars to get a full set of documents
to do a properly done estate basic
estate plan now at what point do you
need to do more than something like that
is his question probably just due to the
complication of your estate if you get
up over about two million dollars I
probably wouldn't go ahead and spend the
money to have an attorney a professional
estate planner do your will the truth is
you do not have any federal estate tax
problem until your estate is over 20
million dollars currently and so if you
don't have a huge huge estate you know
it's actually twenty-two million eight
hundred thousand right now
no federal estate tax on estates smaller
than twenty two million eight hundred
thousand dollars and a very simple a B
marital trust if you are married can
double that and so instead of you know
basically twenty-two and a half you be
at forty four forty five million before
you'd have any taxes with an A B trust
so the way this works is simply this
spouses can receive an unlimited amount
from their spouse with no federal estate
tax it's when the second spouse dies
that you get tagged if you're up over
that twenty two million okay used to be
two million years ago okay but right now
the current law is twenty two point
eight million now so if you leave the
first twenty two point eight million
into a trust when you die and your
spouse has full use of that trust they
can leave another twenty two point eight
million plus that trust without any
taxes that's a simple marital trust and
a B trust and so that's a way to double
the amount for a married couple that you
can shelter from estate tax and believe
me you do want a shelter from estate tax
because the estate tax is fifty five
percent right now and so if you have a
hundred million dollar estate you've
already paid taxes on all of that by the
way you pay taxes on every bit of that
when you got it okay so if you're
sitting on a hundred million dollar
estate into you shelter roughly fifty
million of it you're gonna pay fifty
five percent on fifty million dollars
that you've already paid taxes on and
let me just help you with that that
doesn't I don't think if I was that had
that much money I wouldn't care well
you're supposed to care or you wouldn't
have that much money well they all those
people inherited their money oh my god
one of you people going to stop
believing this mythology the 400
wealthiest people in America today are
the Forbes 400 seventy percent of them
are first-generation 93% of millionaires
are first-generation rich and all the
Forbes 400 are billionaires that's a
thousand million and seven out of ten of
them started with nothing and therefore
have paid taxes on every bit of that
money it's all earned money one way or
another and by the way it's their money
it's not yours they did it you didn't do
it they didn't do anything wrong
Oprah didn't steal from anybody she's
one of them and she's gonna be taxed on
basically nine hundred and fifty million
dollars at fifty five percent and that's
money she's already earned and already
paid taxes on this is how this soak the
rich crap gets translated into stupid
socialism and so taxes on you know death
tax is really what it is it's not an
estate tax is really a death tax we
gonna get you again now that you're not
here that's what it says you've already
paid us once on the income tax you
earned the money you've grown the money
you built something now we're gonna get
you again that's what all that is so do
I sound bitter
yeah I've probably spent a hundred
thousand bucks on the state plans
to keep the government's hands off of
everything in excess of 50 million
dollars so it's just ridiculous now all
that to say let's go back and answer his
question again if you've got about two
million dollars you start to not have a
federal estate tax problem but you
probably have a complicated enough
estate that it's worth spending a few
hundred dollars on an estate planning
attorney on a in the state having a
professional detailed estate plan done
if you've got a hundred thousand bucks
or five hundred thousand bucks or
whatever I wouldn't fool of that I just
get a mama bear legal forms will they're
very they need to be state specific you
always do a will that state specific and
you need to update it anytime there's a
major life event like you move to
another state now your wills not good
because it was specific to the other
state you get married or you get
divorced you your kids grow up and
become my they're no longer minors then
that would change your will like we had
a will set up for our children if
something happened to us everything went
into a trust to care for them in the
event of our death when they were little
well once it grown I don't need that I
can just leave them the money so the
will would change so anytime there's
major life changes you know or moves you
would need to a huge jump and income
probably won't affect your estate tax
but it makes you need to see you need to
stop and think about do I have the right
insurance in place and if they're right
will in place you know jump online at
Dave Ramsey comm use that coverage
checkup tool that's free and it'll tell
it help you figure everything out it's
very very easy or you can text the word
checkup 233 789 bottom line is is all
this stuff is aggravating but it is part
of so it's just managing life keeping
your car tags updated is aggravating you
know keeping your how making sure you
have insurance on your house is
aggravating but it's called grown-up
stuff and so you go and you get your
will done if you've got a complicated
estate if you have a fairly
straightforward thing though don't you
don't have to spend a bunch of money on
it but you do need to get a will 78% of
Americans died without a will
that's just dumber than a rock
you need to get your will done and if
you haven't updated or to looked at it
in five years you need to get out and
look at it and you probably ought to do
a reading of the will to your family
while you're alive if you're gonna piss
everybody off you might as well do it
while you have the chill we're doing it
while you're there right don't do it
from the grave and make them all fight
out with each other and they're really
mad at you so Junior you're doing heroin
you get nothing
I'm not funding your dysfunction you
know Sally you're you're the star of a
reality show and you have no character
you get nothing and so you know this is
you can go ahead and do this while
you're alive we've done it with our
family our family that understands
exactly what we're doing in exactly why
we're doing it and it's very very
important it helps the family actually
go through the grieving process because
they don't go from thinking they hit the
lottery to sheer disappointment in one
fell swoop
right after your death and so just go
ahead and get it all laid out there it's
good for everybody to know what's going
on why create drama
go ahead and get rid of the drama with
good planning and good diligence